[music]
>> I actually did not want
Arshad Farik to
do it. But because they said they're not
sure, I did it.
To make them realize that they can do
it. Otherwise, my intention wasn't
because they should not
come in the picture now.
Sometimes it's good, sometimes it's bad.
For those who like competition, it's
good. They strive harder. Those who
don't like competition, oh, forget it.
Not too much.
Depending on good and bad, also.
For them, they have to break their
records.
So, inshallah, we already have a target
set.
Who can improve Farik? Who'd like to
try?
You can try.
Sorry?
In your style. You'll say.
Okay, try. Okay.
Let's tell him also to try. Okay. Tell
him.
Tell him. Then competition.
Correct?
Suratul Fatiha, chapter number one,
chapter number one, the opening. Suratul
Baqarah, chapter number two, the cow.
The heifer. Suratul Al Imran, chapter
number three, the family of Imran.
Suratul Suratul Nisa, chapter number
four, the women. Suratul Ma'idah,
chapter number five, the table spread.
The hidden Suratul An'am, chapter number
six, the cattle. Suratul A'raf, chapter
number seven, the heights. Suratul
Anfal, chapter number eight, the spoils
of war. Suratul Tawbah, Suratul Bara'ah,
chapter number nine, the repentance, the
disavowal. Suratul Yunus, chapter number
10, Prophet Jonah. Suratul Yusuf,
Suratul
15, the rock track. Suratul Nahl,
chapter number 16, the bee. Suratul
Isra, Suratul Bani Isra'il, chapter
number 17, the night journey, the
children of Israel. Suratul Kahf,
chapter number 18, the cave. Suratul
Maryam, chapter number 19, Mary. Suratul
Taha, chapter number 20, uh the Arabic
letters Taha. Suratul Anbiya, chapter
number 21, the prophets. Suratul Hajj,
chapter number 22, the pilgrimage.
Suratul Mu'minun, chapter number 23, the
believers. Suratul Mu'minun, chapter
number 23, the believers. Suratul Nur,
chapter number 24, the light. Suratul
Furqan, chapter number 25, the
criterion. Masha Allah, takbir.
Takbir.
49.4, masha Allah.
So, now you have two targets.
One is
26 seconds,
46 seconds, and 49 seconds. Three
targets.
So, when you go home now, you have
something to check.
So, inshallah,
when you go home, you can
with the Firdous, you can try.
You did a very good job. Amongst the
participants, masha Allah, you're the
best.
Those that had done before.
So, the credit goes amongst the
participants who are trying it for the
first time,
with the Firdous, masha Allah, done a
very good job.
If you do the same speed without showing
the expression on your face,
it will be better.
But irrespective what your expression
was, masha Allah, you are a fast reader.
From Malaysia,
Chinese origin.
Correct?
Now, masha Allah, training in China is
also very fast.
So, inshallah, I know we have spent
time. I'm relaxed because Isha time, the
later you pray, the better. You can have
the Jamaat, no problem. Third session,
tomorrow is a holiday, rest day.
I'm taking my time.
Are you comfortable or not?
All comfortable.
No firing.
Good.
As long as all of us benefit, I know
one, two, three, four,
five, six,
seven, eight,
nine, 10 people
tried today.
11. Counting them, 11. So, 10 from the
students. So, 10 people had the chance.
Inshallah.
This is I'm letting you say your style.
My style hasn't started yet.
First, get confident in your style.
My style will come later on.
Now, you do your style. No problem. Your
style means the simplest style.
You have a long way to go,
inshallah, before you cross
50% of the training days, which start
from tomorrow. Before 15th day,
inshallah,
we'll see you.
Fine?
And
inshallah, as long as you don't
dig your own grave,
that will enthrall the people. No one
knows that, you know, somebody doing it
at this speed or even if you take for
the full 114 surahs, 5 minutes, 6
minutes,
no problem.
Who knows someone can do it for 2
minutes, 2 and 1/2 minutes? No one
knows. Minutes.
No problem.
Who knows someone can do it for 2
minutes, 2 and 1/2 minutes? No one
knows.
So, here, even if you come out last and
you can clock in 5 minutes, when you go
back, you would be king.
Correct?
5 minutes? Impossible. Where you got
this from?
Actually, I did not teach you.
You have to teach yourself. I cannot
teach.
Allah is there to help everyone. It is
whether you want Allah's help or not.
Fine? And those who have not done, even
you can do wonders. Now, you go home and
say, "Okay, now I have to practice." You
can practice in front of the mirror. No
problem. You can ask your colleague,
"You take my homework, I'll take your
homework." You can give and take.
Many times, when you do your homework,
you require to rehearse.
And I remember when I was young, and yet
I'm young, alhamdulillah.
When I was in the beginning of the field
of Dawah, there's something like guinea
pig. Guinea pig means you can test with.
With my sister.
Anything.
Sister is the punching bag.
How it goes.
Test. Okay, come.
I don't Please, listen to me. Want
someone to look.
Have to give trials.
Even today,
when it's a new lecture, and if I have
the time, I give trial.
Any new lecture I give, unless it's not
asked impromptu.
If I plan a lecture, and if I give, I
always give trial.
Someone asked me to give a topic and I
have to say tomorrow, then comes from my
old stock. No problem. Whatever.
That old stock, it's a re-churning of
what I have. It's not a new matter.
If it's a new matter, the more you
practice, the more confident you are.
And if you're confident,
you know your stuff very well.
Your
technique and everything we'll discuss
day after tomorrow will be better.
is rehearsal.
When I go for talks, people say, "Okay,
give a talk." I said, "Fine, just give
me some time to rest in between."
One is actually to rest, and one is to
prepare. People think, "Oh, computer, no
need of preparation."
No. The more you prepare, the more
confident you are.
So, the key is striving in the way of
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. If you strive,
your pathway is opened. Allah's help
will come. If Allah's help comes, no one
can overcome you.
Correct?
If you strive and the pathway is not
opened, who's to blame?
You yourself.
Allah has promised that if you strive in
his way, he'll open up his pathways for
you.
If his pathway is opened, and Allah's
help comes, none can overcome you.
Sometimes Allah tests people. Ah.
One No sufficient. This person, I'll
make him work for 2 hours or 3 hours.
You work for 2 hours, then you give up.
Allah wants to check.
Allah says in the Quran, in Surah
Baqarah, chapter two, verse number 155,
that surely we will test the moment. Do
you think we'll put you in heaven just
like that? We will test you with your
life, with fear, with death, with the
wealth you have earned.
Test is there.
The more you strive,
the more success you get.
The more success you get,
if you're a true moment, your faith in
Allah increases.
The faith in Allah increases, Allah's
help comes more.
You rise. You rise.
The more you rise, the more humble you
have to become. The better you do, the
more you have to thank Allah.
The more you excel, the more you have to
thank. The more you have to praise Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala because that is the
key. The moment you start thinking
khalas,
I'm a computer, means khalas, gone.
If Allah forsakes you, none can help
you. So, the key is half key. With
Allah's help,
no one can overcome you with half the
key.
That's half. The full is if Allah
forsakes you, none can help you. So,
when you start thinking you have reached
khalas, now I'm ultimate,
Allah will forsake you. Then what will
happen?
None can
help you.
Then you'll have a bigger fall.
The higher you reach, the harder you
fall.
So, one thing is reaching a level, one
thing is maintaining that level.
To reach a level
is very difficult. To maintain is more
difficult.
And there are so many examples. Time
will not permit us. We have really
extended and I think we'll take even the
next homework.
Yes? Do you want the next homework?
Brother Kaleem. No problem. Tomorrow is
a holiday.
Inshallah.
So next homework of Quranic verse will
be taken by Brother Kaleem, Inshallah.
And remember
day after tomorrow, 50 surahs.
Yes?
Inshallah.
Inshallah. If Allah wills, Inshallah.
And
check, huh?
Time yourself.
How much can I clock?
And then you can be more sure whether
you can, you know, a little bit you can.
If I clock 1 minute, okay, maybe I'll do
56, no problem. But if you clock 2
minutes and say I'll do less than 1
minute, then
you unnecessarily trying to say Allah is
in it. You know, I did not strive, I'll
not raise my hand. I'll do it tomorrow
after more practice. Correct? So time
yourself.
Try and excel.
Once you excel, try and put it
in your permanent memory.
Put it in the cache. If it's in the
cache, it'll be easy.
All praise is due to Allah, Lord of the
worlds.
La
ilaha illallah.
ilaha [music] illallah.
Muhammadun
Rasulullah.
Muhammadun [music]
Allahu Allahu Allahu Allahu Allahu
[music] Allahu
Allahu Allahu Allahu Allahu